welcome to this video plane what's the
name of the fat toad from the US got a
French exchange yeah there are many good
lines that's just plain in a symmetrical
way just not too ambitious but very
solid getting the night to to fh maybe
yeah I'm don't want to get the square so
he M took them probably arguing that
dumb but I cannot move the F problem
because of queen bee three okay but I
can take a player 5
this should be too bad for black with
the bishops and no particular problems
at least I don't see honey you can maybe
take and play Knight to c4 c43 that this
is more like a defensive plan drugs of
activity I think white is so bad shape I
ebay also basically needs to take on f6
otherwise I just played c5 and and
better for ya I'm just easily better for
no compensation or whatever okay so just
just bitter b6 probably keep it simple
and now what's the best way to to play
that
I can simply complete development group
d 8 and c5
and it's not from the sss malaysia right
you see the red and white and assume
that it is the US but it's not the case
came just centralized
hmm
yeah they can take it on what about
Queen g7 maybe 27 doesn't he just need
to return now
I don't really believe in a move like
night h6 doesn't really help check
yeah the night is just off side there
so what's the best way to to play even
see 5 immediately well sir not bad at
all taking us probably probably not good
it could take h3 and then take h6
because of Queen g7 at the end this is
funny let's try that
takes h3i take age six if he takes my
bishop I play Queen g7 check and pick up
the rook
and okay just rope g8 is my idea or
taking on h3 his simpler yeah this is
even even simpler check so what is the
best no I can I can give the check but
it's not clear that this is really
winning Bishop to that play Bishop g5 v
takes rook takes let's Queen g7 at the
end and route g8 and cam not not sure
that this is indeed winning but I candy
to move
so are the check first hmm where is this
is this mutt not helping I'm not sure
I'm not sure I don't addressee I don't
see a direct win unfortunately
yeah i'm in the self in
Jim I don't really have a big big threat
here check
hmm he's just going into a self pin
himself great
maybe what would you wanna know no it's
no threat
maybe maybe I can play King g8 next
smooth
so that I'm actually able to to move
this rope time morning check check check
check check check check check check
check check just disappointed by the
course of the game check check check la
coming for chance on chime no yeah yeah
the certs I mean I mean why just watch
this completely out plenty of course the
question is how did I screw it up of
course it's complicated technically that
this is the sold stuff is of course
clearly better for Black Jack I the h6
is especially especially bad but I
didn't refute it I mean this is probably
probably interesting but ok take f6 she
didn't see now black is clearly better
than what did I screw it up yeah rook g6
yeah look g6 is winning yeah Bishop g5
it's probably not enough to really have
an edge he's because he can set up
then this is equal no check and then
yeah this is this is better for right
now with the porn on e3 this is he will
win the pawn check we all care just
continue because i was a bit frustrated
he played so many bad news that really
hurt to not to not have a winning edge
so which means i must have played some
bad moves myself obviously i am maybe
here there are even some ways to improve
but ok it's it's it's clear it's clear
anyway so what more do you want ok i
only need to this is this is also good
which was my first idea take 23 yeah but
it's not not like winning maybe around
here there's some way to improve then 23
is also good or queen d 5 yeah
interesting the one the reason why i'm
saying that why does out plate is ok
with blacks got two bishops I've got the
pawn and he's got basically no choice
then to set up this really passive
position here with the night only three
maybe am I should have even prevented
night f5 altogether and just play Queen
D soon light just prevent it White has
no good moves anyway I play worked yet
the age and c5 that this night doesn't
have a square
this is so according to comp almost upon
the black but I screwed up later alright
thanks for watching